this is very nice l love the mysterty
good, how you doin'
what's up guys just landed in New York City, back again
It's good to be back and the weather's a little bit nicer this time
Got a travelling companion. You might recognise this guy
-What's up guys
Dan from 'What's Inside' we're heading to a hotel
What was that
The YouTube invited us to a creator summit
and
and they call brand cast
So we are both going to be there
It's going to be amazing.This is my first time
My first time as well
O good
Really nice of YouTube to bring us out here
They kind of like treated us very well so far we got picked up and lots of leg room
So I'm just sitting here ready to do some editing
We got an hour drive because I thing here the traffic is terrible
is that but the good thing is in Brooklyn
Right under the Brooklyn Bridge
It's going to take a while to get there but
It's this beautiful place right on the river so
won't take as long as Mathad
So absolutely gorges but
Over here I have a good time here in New York and rocking out daily videos for you
I'm here guys just checked into my hotel
You are not going to believe this view check this out
This is the Brooklyn Bridge
How incredible is that
This is looking out of my hotel room window.
That's amazing
I'm going to go and go for a walk this is to good
Alright room tour
We got our couch and TV over here
This is the bed
YouTube left me little package
Ou fragile. Thank you YouTube.I love you back
man look at this I love the style
And
I don't know they are real
Ok not real but still looks cool
This is the bathroom area with the sink and shower
Very very cool
O check this out I also got my badge
Grant Thomson the king of random
with the creator summit
And it just wouldn't to leave the hotel room without unboxing this would it.
let's go ahead and open this thing up and see we got.
Wrappers off we are going inside
O look at this
O I got a heart from YouTube
O thanks YouTube you guys are amazing I love you back
O cool so if you like this postcard you could to other creators
Be on the look it
be on the lookout
I don't know what I'm trying to say but I'm definitely get more of those
Alright looks like we got a map to go exploring and exploring sounds like a really fun thing to do so
Cool
Oh nice feel the loungen
Got a swell bottle
Oh a shirt,it's pretty oh it's a jacket that's pretty cool
So I get freshen up a little bit, make a call to my wife and I think we go out and exploring
You are coming with me
So over here we have our spiraling whirlpool of death
which or so reason I'm overwhelming and jump in
Brooklyn Bridge in background and right over here is the hotel we stayed in
Very nice
Alright cool kinda go for a walk
I call this a random meeting
Very random very random
You saw this guy.This is AVfamily
How your doing.What's up
and he come back to near to try the pizza and turns I don't have to buy it
but I'm going to contribute well you can pay for it
Take it Dan you are a good man I got it
I get the last piece
Quick update guys
I had a nice little walk outside it was extremely windy though tables and chairs blin and the trees are going cracy
I also stopped into a random pizza place to get something to eat
I rented Dan from wants inside and Andrae  form AVfamily which is pretty cool
Now YouTube is having a private party up on the roof so we are heading there next
And here we are good morning guys its the next day last night was an awesome party up on the roof top tenth floor met a lot of really cool creators
Today going to do some meditation,check out the local New York scene,get some breakfast and we got the YouTube creator summit
Umm actually this look really good
I have been doing to keep you guys updated
So we did a really cool summer,creator summit learned from so many great people and now we are heading glass blowing instructions
Derek  from Veritasium how you doing
and we are going to learn how is this things work if we can figure it out we might be able to go home build our own little glass blowing metal foundry
O who's that its Row
Here we go achievement unlocked last blower status
Hey me too it way better that trust me
Collins Keys go check it out we are going to do something pretty soon could be later
Made the polaried wall its taking a few seconds to develop here but that's the basic idea
Check it out on the YouTube Instagram boom
There it is what
Good morning guys its the next day again kinda late night last night so
Today is going to be an exciting day we got a special guest coming out Madsentero sneaking round the background there and
check this out we got a polaried wall so this is were all the pictures are from all the different creators you may recognize
some of them some up incomings that are rocking Instagram we had Matpat over here we had oh the king of random over there then we got
Madsentero who is still tied developing
So this is Mad mad working up
He got me on the green juice with the gingers so we don't get sick but I did kind of lost my voice already
Look at the science its its disappearing
That will be a sweet time lapse yeah right I was just thinking that
We will leave that show me the time lapse about this ok your packs are developing
Right hahahaha you know
I'm back again guys we just met Will Smith he is almost as cool as this guy you know this guy he is 100 times as cool as me
Over here we got the infernes
Hey buddy how are you harm for you
Stay wild
We are on a water taxi right now Statue of Liberty is right over there and after this an adventure we are going to a brackhole Brandcast
So we are on our way to Brandcast right now probably two blocks away from the advace we are getting police escort and security detail
Probably police protection
O hey what's up everybody how's doing
Don't waste your time
Hey king of random what's up
You got a great channel thank you man
So yeah Brandcast amazing event just had a performance Kadi perri finished up heading back to hotel little after party that's pretty much info for this event
AMAZING
White tie I was going to do the elder edge knot but I didn't have the time to figure out how to tie